Ron Hosko is the former assistant
director of the FBI and he joins us that
Mahaska thanks a lot for coming on I
want to read you in exchange between
unnamed FBI employees on election night
I can't stop crying says one I am numb
says another I'm so stressed about what
I could have done differently I think
the FBI's influence may have had an
effect in this I don't know
we broke the momentum being the momentum
of the Hillary Clinton campaign so here
you have unnamed FBI employees lamenting
the fact that they couldn't help a
specific political candidate become
president what's your reaction to that
you know it kind of sickens me Tucker I
think those employees those mentioned in
this report have failed the organization
they've failed the expectation of the
highest degree of professionalism
they've let their their biases perhaps
intersect with an investigation
so it's deeply concerning and I think
Christopher Rhea is determining take
some action on that I'm confused though
as to why we don't have a right to know
who these people are and what they're
doing now I mean if you write in an
email and apparently this is real we
broke the momentum we hurt Hillary we
shouldn't done that I'm heartbroken that
she lost don't I have as a citizen to
write to know what you're doing now who
are you
who wrote that I mean these are public
employees well they are public employees
but there's also a public process
there's an internal disciplinary process
it sounds as though a number of
employees have been referred to that
process and so just like the director
said in his press conference today he's
going to hold off on that and follow
standing policy until those issues are
resolved now we may learn who that is
later quite clearly we've seen and heard
some of the text messages and IMS back
and forth with struck and page they're
very very concerning and trust me that
the work force is hurt by that and
they're offended by it yeah and all the
other people who are investigated by by
struck and page and the rest of these
have grounds for reopening cases I would
think anyway Ron Hosko thank you great
to see you
you too